Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau.
- Lors du congrès annuel de la
Société européenne d'oncologie
médicale, une équipe anglaise a
des particules fines dansle dévr
du poumon.
Labo. section hématologie, CHUM
- On est en train de pouvoir
indiquer que des petites
particules dans l'air, qui
peuvent causer l'émergence
de typesde types de cancer que
l'on n'avait pas vu avant
il y a 20 ou 25 ans.particules
fines notamment dans les gazd'ée
industrielle, ou issues du
chauffage au bois. Elles sones e
anglaise n'a pas encore été
revue par des paires, mais elle
indique les particules fines
pourraient affecte, qui elles
déclencheraient des changements
dans deux gênes, déjà liés
au cancer du poumon.
- Des trde moins de 2.5 5m peuvt
causer au niveau des poumons,
mais problème aussi au niveau
d'autres tissus,
inflammation va elle-même causer
des altérations secondaires
au niveau des tissus qui sont
atteints et par le fait même,
des types de cancer.
- C'est une avancée importante,
qui braque les projecteurs
sur l'importance de la réduction
Dre MARIE-CLAUDE LETELLIER
v.-p., Assoc. médecine prév. Qc
- Le meilleur moyen de prévenir
la maladie, c'est d'enleverà la.
- Pour prévenir, encore
faudrait-il avoir un registre
des tumeurs au Québec.y en a pae
le docteur Soulières.
- C'est qu'il y a dans certaines
zones du Québec par exemple, gre
de certains types de cancer
et en se demandant qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans l'environnemeà ct
en sorte que certains types
de cancer sont plus prévalant
que dans les autre
- Selon le ministère de
l'Environnement, en 2021
le Québec a vécu en moyenne
12 jours
qualité de l'air.
Or à certains enertains endroita
Capitale-Nationale, de l'Abitibi
Témiscam
les résidents en ont subi encore
it entre 31 et 43 jours.
Un enjeu trop peu abordé durant
selon certains.
Ici Marie-Josée
Paquett